hello everyone when webinar onion 1/2
2015 single cup Garry Kasparov posted
his famous tweet that the chess world is
a better place when Levin Aragon is
playing well and indeed 11 Arnon really
is playing well this is a game from
round 6 of the single cup and he's
playing against what we saw and well
this game is really really spectacular
and I guess REM decided to challenge
Island for the best game of the
tournament after that the game aren't
played against Korra wanna so I'm
interested to hear which game do you
prefer I mean which game is better to
your taste but let's see the game Aragon
is the white and and the Wesley so is
black we have d4 by our engine Knight to
f6 c4 e6 Knight to f3
what's so transposes into the Queens
gambit declined would be 5 9 2 C 3
Bishop to b4 we have a Bishop to g5 h6
Bishop captures on f6 Queen casters on
f6 and our Queen to a poor trick with an
attack on the bishop on before so nice
to see 6 defending both threats III
Wesley castles Bishop to e2 and now D
captures on c4 and Doronin castles she's
not really in a hurry to pick up this c4
pawn as it can't really be defended
Wesley plays Bishop captures on c3 we
have B captors on c3 and now Bishop to
d7 and only now desiring on capture this
pawn so can capture some c4 and what's
the place rook to c8 and this is a good
move as the knight can now freely move
since the Queen was kind of attacking
the c7 pawn and rook will definitely
become active on e on CAS after c5 is
played in the future
so we have R ok to d1 rook f38 night to
d2 and this nice to do more to move this
is a pretty standard move in positions
like this white want to play F 3 and d 4
and it's also kind of threatening a
tempo with Knight d4 attacking the Queen
so this could come in handy
we have Knight to a5 Queen to b4 now
taking the knight and a 5 and also to be
7 point so Wesley stop this by simply
playing b6
and this is the position that I really
enjoy the entire game is great but what
our engine plays in this position really
shows why he is well again in the 2800
club he plays Bishop to a6 and attack
this rook and like I said this Rooker
would have become really a really active
on c8 after c5 was played so our onion
before he continues with his plan
decides that he wants to kind of
misplace this row can be 8 so rook to b8
and only now there's our onion play
Knight to e4 with the temple on the
Queen we have Queen to f5 and now Bishop
to d3 and we have Bishop to Bishop to c6
because well then I doesn't really have
any good discoveries and Aragon plays a
strong move here
he plays f3 well we have Bishop captures
on e4 and now s captures any for now
opening the SAP file which will prove to
be quite deadly what's the place Queen
to g5 going for this week a week III
pawn and rook the f3 c 5 and of course
our engine doesn't wanna capture and c5
she wants this row can be a to stay in
inactive Queen to be - and now e5 where
Wesa so rook d2 f1 doubling up on the F
file pink after sandy for C capture
sandy for and rook the b7 and with this
rook - b7 move defends f7 and well this
is this is a good move and is also
prepares rook to c7 to occupy this C
file for his own rook we have d5 by our
onion and our rook to c7 and this is
what I really enjoy do you see how many
moves it took to activate this rook if
this rook was in CH then it would have
been active all the time
so this Bishop to a6 and then back to D
3 idea was was simply brilliant y11 R&M
and this gained the iron and just enough
tempos to to continue with his plan and
the onion is becoming kind of famous for
for winning brilliance is by playing the
move h4 and this game is no different he
wants to win this 'if i've gone but he
can't really play rook that v you know
to attack the Queen and the pawn because
because of this week III porn so natural
he plays h4 now kicking the Queen and
the king has to capture if she moves to
h5 then this rope that five idea is
definitely a possibility so we have rook
captures and earth Queen captures and h4
and Queen captures and e5 attacking the
rook on c7 Queen three seven defending
and now Queen to g3 and what is so plays
Queen to c5 again kind of threatening
this e3 pawn if the rock ever moves but
iron and finds a brilliant move and it's
from this position to the end it's blow
by blow by blow by Aragon he plays rook
to f6 and this is well extremely
unpleasant Erin's idea is well pretty
simple he wants to capture this h6 pawn
and open the H file and after the H file
opens it's it's a quick death for black
so Wesley tries to stop this with pawn
to h5 but now another blow by RN and he
plays rook to h6
and again rook cannot be captured and
now he's threatening rook captures an h5
and it's not really easy to stop this
and nothing can you know come between
this point except maybe just g6 but this
would be over quickly so what's the
trice Queen to c3 now protecting g7 and
also attacking this Bishop on on d3 but
our engine simply captures it rook
captures on h5 and this bishop cannot be
captured if it's a point with verts
caster this vision than simply Queen to
h4 and the game is over and now
threatening checkmate on a chase and
also threatening screen captures on d8
checkmate so two unstoppable threat
so after up to h5 let's ride try g6 now
attacking will the rook of course it
cannot be captured but now the queen is
protecting h8 so Queen to h4 isn't
deadly right away but Erin finishes the
game quite nicely
he plays e5 and well now the queen is no
longer protecting h8 and in this
position wes is so resigned the bishop
still cannot be captured
if you if you want to try to find out
for ourselves why the bishop cannot be
captured you're free to do so it's not a
it's not an easy continuation to find so
feel free to do it and for those of you
who tried I congratulate you it was it's
a very silent move and you're very
strong flurries were found it but after
clink after sandy 3 our engine had in
mind this rook to h3 move and now the
threat of a Queen to h4 with this
checkmate NHS and the threat of
capturing the rock is still in the game
so after something like rook to f8 Queen
to h4 now threatening checkmate on a
chase and f5 as Queen to HH check King
to s7 Queen to h7 check King te 8 and
simply Queen captures on c7 and well
with these amazing central pawns in this
rook ready to jump on HSN this would be
over well very soon for example Queen
captures on d5 and rook to h7 and there
really aren't any moves for black to
play here so yeah definitely it
definitely a brilliant game by our onion
and like I said it's like he challenges
and for who played the best game this
tournament and I hope that every every
run will have at least one game like
this and yeah Aragon is at the moment
tied with Magnus Carlsen and iron for
second place first place is still held
by the by Raffaella Grove and it's going
to be a very very strong tournament a
very very you know very tight score at
the top so yeah that's it
thank you for watching and I would like
to thank Michael Keenan fettering sin
Halley for your contributions to my
channel I do appreciate it thank you
very much and as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here and that's it
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon